nina Harnum us go on the start good
morning good morning it's another
beautifully foggy rainy day here Florida
we are off to the animal kingdom are we
excited yes update Hayden's leg is a
little bit better but he's having a hard
time keeping his leg straight on one leg
so I'm probably gonna go for a
wheelchair today and you'll feel
hopefully better and last night one of
my YouTube fans Adam he's a rapper
connected with me and we're probably
gonna find the time to meet up and
that'll be fun here we are at Disney's
Animal Kingdom who's excited me all
right me too we're on the trim on the
way to the animal kingdom Hayden has an
animal in his head all right we're at
the Kilimanjaro safaris about to go on
we got hate in his own special
wheelchair because he can't walk he's
hopping on one leg and it's easier we
get to go to the front of the line with
the wheelchair so I don't have to carry
you everywhere ha why are you eating
your key mr. dude take that I am Ralph
is your key
is Nina Nina has an awesome shirt on
today
okay what animals you hope we see on the
ride but i can see badges animals in
Africa Wow cheetahs okay to put them in
your mouth you okay these are all the
animals that were supposed to here we
are this is hayden he's an explorer with
a shark on his head that's Nina Nina and
I met him at the Mexico pavilion I
picked her up and she join us along
what's your name huh imagine meeting you
and a place like this aren't we happy we
brought Nina along yeah look at that
horn
Nina wanted something healthy so we got
her the hot breakfast wrap with eggs
sausage spinach and goat cheese and here
she is about to try it and very
spinachy-- whoa it's not great okay okay
keep moving next up is the pangani force
exploration trail we get to walk and see
some animals the ancient Chinese Nina
Hana mas the Nina Hana miss is very sexy
but also wild and dangerous I think Nina
could catch him though Nina is pretty
fast huh but I think Nina could you
catch up oh look at you mean you can
realize I'm like a real ax a little bit
he didn't really wanted to see bats so
we're going to the Maharaja jungle trek
and it says that you will see Tigers
giant bats and lovely birds what do you
think you gonna go walk can you pretend
you're a bath we're about to watch bugs
life while these are silly glasses
to me a week so we're here we're here
having lunch I've got a meat lovers tiny
pizza Hayden has a cheese pizza with
broccoli and apple juice and Nina has a
romaine salad
Nick's hand we got a coke no this was 30
something dollars
I
almost
anyway it's a huge ripoff but we're
going to eat this divine the street
performer who is behind me and you can
see her walking it was rated as a
must-see attractions so let's go check
her out so we are at the birds of wonder
show now we're going to see some bird
paintings all excited it's a special
seat what do you think you're going to
pretend to be a bird
hey don't look sad go on the star again
hmm all right up next festival of the
Lion King so Hayden and Nina have
discovered that they can play
fieldrunners as a team where they each
have a side all right here we are inside
the lion king stage hey Dineen are
playing some guild of Thieves still
digging beat her energy this is a cool
theater where everything happens in the
middle so the seats are all around the
outside and the forwards in your middle
so be fun to see how this goes
hi
Oh
last ride of the day Triceratops spin
all right here we go i'm in charge of
shelton forward and back and hayden
hayden Anina charge i'm going up and
down just haven last ride of the day are
you tired are you excited you gonna
sound excited all day has been craving a
turkey leg so are the trilobites to get
a jumbo turkey leg for Nina they're
looking pretty tired of hungry so I
better make it fast to get a fun look at
the size of this ridiculous leg it's
bigger than Nina's hedge is going to
freak out Freddie
Oh
Thanks is huge Wow
okay that's art that's it for animal
kingdom bye bye Oh LeBron's happening
here okay self-improvement books are
like fitness books they never work on
their own what you need is a trainer
that's Evan get the newsletter
you